on Sunday afternoon the tense week-long
waiting game was over the strike that
Hezbollah had been promising was
underway anti-tank missiles fired at an
Israeli army base near the community of
Aviv in just south of the Lebanese
border Hezbollah's al-manar TV claimed
an Israeli tank had been destroyed and
soldiers killed but the Israeli military
said while its base had sustained hits
no soldiers had died Israeli artillery
and air strikes targeted Lebanese border
areas but reports from there said the
shells hit mainly empty areas no
casualties were reported on either side
less than two hours after it had begun
the Israeli army said the confrontation
appeared to be over and we were attacked
by several anti-tank missiles we're
tally ated with about a hundred shells
from the air and by other means
we're holding consultation concerning
the future I ordered them to be prepared
as you know for any possibility we have
no casualties not even a scratch
the latest escalation started a week ago
Hezbollah said an attack on a stronghold
in southern Beirut last Sunday was
carried out by Israeli drones it
followed an Israeli air strike that
killed two Hezbollah fighters in Syria
Israel said it had prevented a drone
attack being launched from there yes and
Hezbollah as leader Hassan Nasrallah
warned then and repeated on Saturday
that his forces would strike back and he
denied Israel's justification for its
recent attacks that Hezbollah and Iran
were assembling precision guided
missiles inside Lebanon yeah amid why
Netanyahu lumo a settlement when its
ally a pretext Netanyahu is using to
attack and I said on many occasions that
we have enough guided missiles for what
we need but not precision guided missile
factories now Djimon Netanyahu insists
Iran's growing threat necessitates an
expanding Israeli response it's just
over two weeks until the Israeli
elections forceful action backs up his
carefully nurtured image as Israel's mr.
security that are sent into full-scale
war on the Lebanon board
less so in the week since Hassan
Nasrallah gave his warning of a
retaliatory strike all of the messaging
from both sides all of the analysis
suggested that neither Israel nor
Hezbollah wanted an escalation towards
all-out war and in their actions earlier
on Sunday they appear to have proved
that right limiting and calibrating
their military actions to satisfy the
domestic audiences without for now at
least triggering a broader conflict
Harry Fawcett al-jazeera just outside of
even in northern Israel